I have a quick shout out to give to my
audience today for being so generous and
kind as part of our winter wonderland we
have this giving tree and all week
audience members have been bringing
gifts to help the kids at the Union
rescue mission have a very Merry
Christmas it's very kind of you you'll
all rock thank you so much
having children it's the we know how
important it is to get something during
Christmas so I think I love the fact
that we're going to do something or the
pants rather than always receive it it's
just a special to think of someone else
but not expected in return so it's
really nice that you provided this
opportunity and encouraged so thank you
when you're fortunate a family and
friends even if it's just a simple job
and place to live there's so many kids
and other people who don't have those
luxuries and so I think the fact that we
can give gifts and just help a kid and
smile on Christmas can make a huge
difference in their life next year or
even that day you know the spirit of
Christmas is being with family spending
time with people that you love giving
back to those who are less fortunate
than we are and just you know time
together we got fun toys for different
kids so we within our group we got like
every age and both genders so that we
were making sure everybody got stuff
warm jammies and gloves my daughter
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this